[Music]
in 2005 the Academy awarded a technical
achievement award to Edwin Catmull
Turney to rose and your star for the
research and implementation of
subdivision surfaces a modeling
technique used in motion picture
computer graphics it's the foundation
for almost all of the visual effects and
animation you see in movies today and
thank goodness because without it my
daughter wouldn't be able to watch
frozen three hundred times a week thanks
guys
thumbs up since then the widespread
impact of this geometric construct is
being heralded again by the Academy with
an upgraded award as well as recognizing
a new recipient to receive honors for
his additional research on subdivision
surfaces
first to Charles Luke for his research
into subdivision surfaces based on
triangles the Academy presents a
technical achievement award come and get
it
[Applause]
I'd like to thank the Academy and the
SCI tech awards committee I'd also like
to thank my lovely wife for almost
making it here tonight she's stuck in a
snowstorm I would not be standing up
here tonight and it's hard to believe
that I am standing up here tonight if
not for Tony De Rose Tony was a mentor
who went to bat for me many times his
influence allowed me to have a career
where I get to play rather than work
I may have introduced my subdivision
algorithms to Tony but Tony gave it my
name and introduced it to the world
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]